- Why you should not go into consulting.
This is the topic for today's video.
It's a bit of an unusual topic if you know
the other videos on my channel,
and indeed I also want to make the format
of today's video a little
bit different than otherwise
because today I really want
to give you a real talk.
I want to show some real stories to you,
tell you really about
my personal experiences
and thereby talk about
why I really think that
for some people probably
consulting is not the right thing.
And also really explain that to you.
What really the downsides
of the career are.
I hope also touch a couple of things
which are not the obvious reasons.
Like you travel a lot,
I think we all know this
but let's really go into
the details of this.
And so indeed the format
I want to do it here today
also in the video format is that
I will just sit down here with you.
I wrote a couple of notes
here on my piece of paper
and I just really want to have a
a heart to heart conversation with you,
which is really Frank, probably also
a bit less edited this video than usual
so apologize if maybe
I just talk a bit more
or are less structured
than usual, because again
this would just be due to
the nature of this video
just because I want to be as frank
and as open as possible with you today.
So in this spirit welcome
to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
I will of course drink coffee
as usual. And I will probably put it down
here next to me, but please do not wonder
if I'll casually pick it up again.
On my channel I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
And again, just to start this also off
to make sure that I'm not
being misunderstood here.
If you've seen other videos on my channel,
you know that I'm in general
a very big fan of consulting.
I'm a very big proponent of consulting
and this was not just
fake, I truly believe that
I truly believe that consulting is a great
extraordinary career opportunity
for many many people out there,
I really mean this by heart.
Though it's not only positive
what you experience there,
for sure I had some dark moments for sure
to me there happened things
which weren't that great.
And I want to talk
about this as well, also
on the channel, just, just in
terms of being fair, right?
Because I believe that if you decide
yourself to start
consulting, then you should
know what you're getting yourself into.
And then also what maybe some things are
which may be a bit nicer
in other career paths.
Because of course, even
though I like consulting
a lot by no means I want to claim that
consulting is the only career path
that you can pursue to become successful
or to be happy or to have a great life.
Of course, there are
many other alternatives.
I mean, I hope that
this is obvious as well.
So let's talk about these things.
And I have prepared three
points I want to talk about.
And maybe if we just kind of
read the topic of the point
it might sound a bit
obvious to you, but again
I hope to touch also a couple
of not so obvious points here.
And the first point I want
to talk about is the pressure
the pressure that you will
feel when working in consulting
especially also as a junior,
really from the start.
And here just really try to put yourselves
in the shoes of a young consultant.
How will your day look like?
And I'm especially as always talking
about these very large tier
one strategy consulting firms
with some other firms that
might be a bit different.
Of course not all firms are the
same and so on and so forth.
You know this right?
But let's talk about this type of firm.
And indeed they're often from day one,
from week one after the
first onboarding days or so
you will be sitting at the client
on an actual client project,
and you will have
significant responsibilities.
The team sizes are very small on a typical
MBB type of project, It will be one of
two, three, four, five consultants.
And you will very early on be
responsible for full work stream.
And if for whatever
reason your work stream
isn't doing well the pressure is on.
Let me just tell you this.
Because everybody is so
loaded, so full of work.
It's not the case as in many other
larger companies that
your colleagues can just
pick up the work, can just help you out
necessarily can just do the work for you,
for whatever reason, you
do not really manage.
Of course there will be a project lead
who will coach you, who will help you,
who will really benefit you also try to
develop you, and in difficult
meetings, also join you.
But even then very early
you will have meetings.
With also rather senior
clients on many projects.
Alone, you will sit alone with them.
And then, again, for all kinds
of reasons that wouldn't be unusual
that maybe a client isn't happy with you,
with your work, with the
value that you deliver
with the results that you bring.
And he will criticize
you and you might not get
along well with him, or her,
or whatever the client is.
The client might complain
to your project lead,
to your partner. And then
depending on how it goes,
I mean, again depends
on the circumstances,
but then rather quickly sometimes
you will really also be very quickly
in the focus of the critique.
And if this happens, also just mentally,
psychologically that
can be extremely tough.
Imagine going into the
team room every day,
you're working with clients who you know
don't like you don't appreciate you
don't want to work with you.
And of course this also often
has political reasons, right?
Some clients might
literally be incentivized
to not make you succeed, to make you fail.
And of course, in an ideal situation
your team will recognize
this, will help you out.
will support you, And this is also
how it is most of the
times, but not always.
And you know, this can really be tough.
And I also made a video about that,
talking about stress and
anxiety in situations like this
I will link it somewhere above here
where I'm sharing things like this.
And I also explaining a bit
more also more personal stories.
But I mean, I can tell you,
let, let me be honest here.
I have projects where I really
just felt like so miserable.
It was psychologically so bad.
I remember one time I just
went to the client toilet
locked myself into a toilet cabin
and just because I couldn't
handle the situation anymore
in the team room, sitting
together with the colleagues
just coming out of a client meeting
just really being heavily
criticized by the client.
And then also often feeling powerless
because sometimes of course the criticism
is right, but especially as a junior,
you will lack sometimes
also the political agility
to really play this in the right way.
There are also things that
are out of your control.
And very frankly, I've seen colleagues
who just were crushed by that.
I mean, who really spent
like one or two years
in this atmosphere and
really psychologically
mentally, probably even had like some more
or less like lasting damages from that
because it can be like extremely
difficult, extremely tough.
And if you do not develop some
some really mental resilience strategies
then this can really take a toll on you.
And again now, I, also
don't take me wrong.
I don't want to now make
consulting sound like
mental abuse or anything like that.
I mean, clearly there are many, many
other things where you
have much worse experience
than what you can experience there.
But again, a thing on some people
it can be extremely tough,
extremely difficult.
I for sure had my dark moments as well.
I believe there's like,
almost no consultant
for sure no consultant I personally know
who didn't have like one or two situations
on projects, but I really feel badly
also really mentally for
all kinds of reasons.
Of course, the great
thing in consulting is
that then, after the project is
always the next project where you then
work with a new team, with a new client,
with a new situation.
And also here in terms of your career
only if you fail on one project,
for whatever reason this doesn't mean
that you need to leave the firm
or that you need to get
kicked out or whatever, right?
I mean, it's not like that, but still,
this mental pressure is a thing.
And also like to compare
this to some other jobs
because I mean, there
are jobs where you just
go into the office, you sit
down there, you do your work.
And then at 5 or 6:00
PM, you leave the office.
And then at home there's
really nothing else
you need to think about anymore.
Like you have like an empty head.
These are these more, If you
want to call it this way,
simple jobs, I don't know, don't mean this
in any derogatory way,
but this for sure is not
how your job in consulting will be.
I mean, you will leave the office,
You will sit at your desk at night,
late at night still continue to work
potentially late after midnight,
next morning, back in the team room.
And then on the Friday on the weekend.
Yes. Like there's a strong culture
at least what I experienced to
not work on the weekend, but for sure,
you're already thinking of Monday.
I mean, clearly it's not a job
that you just have an empty head
once you're home or anything like this.
Especially if you compare
this to some other careers.
So this is the first
truth, The first downside
the first thing you need to
be aware of; this pressure.
And of course, many
things I just talked about
are very closely and directly related also
to the learning curve.
I mean, these are situations just
while you learn so much, I mean,
it is just because you
are under so much pressure
that you develop yourself
in such a quick way
that you need to learn
this political game.
You need to learn to
interacting with senior clients
that have their own agenda and so on.
I mean, also again you
need to understand that
this is closely linked, right?
But still, this is part
of the reality as well.
This is what it is.
So hope I didn't talk
already talk too much
and too long here, I
have a bit of a feeling
this one might get into
a bit of a longer video
but let me now take a sip of coffee here.
And because of the second
point, I want to talk
about the second thing
that I believe really
people underestimate
is this travel aspect.
And I know I said this
in the beginning that I
don't want to talk too much
about the obvious stuff.
So let's cover that quickly first, right?
So what I mean what is the obvious stuff
about the whole travel discussion?
Of course you will be away
from home Monday to Thursday.
Again, I will link another video up here
where I talked about the typical work week
in the life of a consultant
if this interests you.
How, like, the schedule
looks like where you are
at what point in time,
at least, especially like
until end of 2019 before the
current health situation.
Of course, most people are at home office
but how this plays out,
have a look at that video.
But what I really mean
with the travel is that
it's really more than that, right?
And of course the one part of it is that
it can be very glamorous and, you know
you might fly business
class around the country
a lot of course that feels glamorous.
You have all the status cards of all the
airlines, of all the big hotel chains.
You might stay in some great,
very, very amazing hotels.
These are the nice aspects.
And yes, this is nice,
and even after several years,
I still enjoyed that, okay?
I mean, with the downside of course
that you are away from
home, away from the family.
This is still the nice aspect.
But still the reality is
that not every project
is in a nice big city where you have
this infrastructure where
you can enjoy all this.
And for me, probably
at least every third or
every fourth project
for me was at some place
very deep, like in the middle of nowhere
in the countryside where it
was really difficult to get to.
I mean, I will remember being like at some
very very rural location in the UK.
there was only a discount
carrier taking you there.
So for sure, nothing like business class
or any like great status with lounges
or so experienced at the airport.
Then there was a long
ride with the, with a car.
Then we need to get that location
on the logistics would
take you hours every day,
would mean that you would need to wake up
I believe I was waking up at 4:00 AM
every Monday just to get there.
And it was like super late when
I arrived back on Thursday.
But then also these places often
there aren't great hotels
or anything like that.
So especially at this
point, I was in a hotel.
It was like really not a great hotel.
And I'm, I'm not like, it's not even that,
you know, I'm the guy who
to whom it is so important,
that it's so luxurious or whatever
but it was really not a great place.
It was in the winter, it was cold
I remember freezing at night because
the heating in this hotel
wasn't working properly.
I just needed to like
take several sweatshirts
on just because I was literally
freezing there, right?
The food was super bad, there was not
any restaurant close by that had
well, like a decent food quality.
And of course, this is so demoralizing.
If, you know, you work so much,
you work so late and you
are in the hotel room
and then it's cold and the food is bad.
And I mean, this just adds so much
to this also really mental
pressure that you have.
And again, there are some glamorous parts.
Sometimes it can be great.
Again, I had great
experiences in amazing hotels.
Of course, these are the nice sites
but don't underestimate
how many also very big
very large companies have sometimes
their headquarters at
very, very rural places.
Or of course, you are not
always at the headquarters.
Maybe you are working
in, in, in production.
And then you are in
some production factory
somewhere in the middle of nowhere
working with these people, um,
it can be tough. And this again, adds
to this mental situation, to the pressure.
It adds to this overall sometimes really
really bad situation that you
can then find yourself in.
This is just also part of the reality.
This was the second point I
wanted to share here today.
The third point is the learning curve.
And specifically what's maybe
not so great about the learning curve.
Because most people want
to join consulting, who
are interested in a career
in consulting do this
because they believe that the
learning curve is amazing.
And again, like, overall, I agree.
Overall I believe the
learning curve is great
is amazing, at least much better
than most other career
paths that you can take.
Because specifically
you just have exposure
to a very high number of industries,
a very high number of different functions.
Like probably there's no
other career path where like
in a couple of years you
will likely have worked
in retail, in automotive, in pharma,
in telecommunications, I mean, really
what you see what you can do is great.
Those third, to some extent
it does get repetitive.
This is also part of the truth.
And probably this is even worse in,
for instance, IT consulting types of firms
where the projects are even longer
the type of projects that
you do are even more similar.
But I would argue even
in strategy consulting
MBB type of consulting
firms, it gets repetitive.
Not necessarily regarding
the contents that you do
because often yes, it is different.
But even here over time you will
be asked to specialize more and more,
After two or three years,
you will really focus
much more on specific industries,
specific types of functions,
of types of projects
because of course is
then valuable knowledge.
And then of course, everybody
wants you to do this again
because this is the
really something you've
learned, that you're really good at.
I mean, it makes sense, but of course
then the content start to
repeat after some time.
But even if you do do different things
the overall structure, the type
of things that you do are very similar.
I mean, always like in
the first week, you always
have a client kickoff, to
prepare this client kickoff.
Then you start the project,
you have expert calls,
calls with internal
experts, other partners
who did similar things
already in the past,
maybe some external aspects,
experts that you talk to.
This is then this next phase.
Then you have your
weekly, your fix meetings,
your weekly regular
meetings with the clients
where then you always prepare
the thorough fix document.
You talk about this with the client
then you prepare your
analysis, get some data
build an Excel model, crunch the numbers
derive this, share this
back with the client,
discuss it, then every second week
you have a steerco.
So it's a big steering committee
the big committee where usually
with board level type of members,
you discuss then the results.
Again, the process is always the same.
The partner comes in,
discuss this with you.
Then you do an iteration
loop, another iteration loop
until you have the
document then present it
in front of the board, get the feedback.
So this kind of type of
activities that you do.
These types of discussions.
It really starts to get
repetitive after some point, again,
probably much more interesting
than many other career jobs
but after you did this a couple of years
it doesn't necessarily
feel like this anymore
like the very first time, like
the very first years you do this.
And of course, this is
also part of the reason,
why then after a couple of years,
many people do switch, right?
Many people do then transition.
And of course then once
you're project lead
the new experience that you add is really
managing the team, leading the team.
This is a new experience.
Once you are then a partner,
here the new experience
is really, are you responsible
for acquiring new business, doing sales,
If you want to call it this way
of course this is a new experience.
But I would argue
depending on what exactly
that you do, but then there are
some exit paths that you
could take that really
then increase your
learning curve much more.
And here one of the things I missed most
in terms of consulting
in terms of the learning
for sure was really this
operational experience
because let's be frank,
it's very different
to just be the expert
just tell other people
in a smart way, what they should do.
You know, this one thing, and of course,
this is important and
a great skill to have
you understand
intellectually what's right,
but then really implementing
something like this
in an organization, talking to the people,
making them do the things
that you want them to do.
All of this might sound
obvious to you as a consultant.
And probably I even thought
that this was rather easy,
you know, when I was a consultant.
But now after a couple of years and more
operational roads after I have consulting.
So you want to divert for two years at a
at a CTO position in a retail company.
Now, since this year transitioned
into a chief revenue officer position
at a medium sized company here in Munich.
When you're responsible for your team
and you need to talk and
work with real people.
And maybe then also with people where not
everybody has an Ivy
league education where not
everybody is getting
paid a six digit salary
because of course these people
are then super motivated,
will do everything you
ask them to do, right?
But maybe with people
also with other profiles
motivating these people, influencing them
to really work together with you
on the things that are important to you.
And then also that they do it the way
that you believe is right,
and you know is right.
This is really a significant challenge.
And I really think that
this is an experience
that you do not learn, do not get
in consulting because there,
for you often just stops
in the theory and is for
most types of projects.
So this is my third
point. Let me just recap,
First, the pressure that you are on,
early on can be immense,
can be unbearable.
At least it feels at
times that it's unbearable
and can really crush you, especially
if you are, like your mental health
isn't already in a strong
place at the beginning.
You're not really able to build
some good resilience strategies here.
Second, this travel that just adds
on it can be really, really tough for you.
And third, the sort of repetition.
Yes, the learning curve
is great, but maybe
not always as great as
you think it is, or,
as you think it will be
when you join consulting.
These are my truths. These are the things
where I believe that
maybe consulting is not
the right career path for everybody.
And at least I believe it's very fair
that you know about this before
you start your career in consulting.
This is just my perspective, my opinion,
of course, I trust other people
might've had different experiences also.
So I'm not claiming that this is now
the reality, the truth for everybody.
I love to get your
perspective on that as well.
I mean, what were these
maybe darker moments
darker situations, not so
great experiences that you had.
Let me know in the comments I'd love to,
to, to interact with you on that.
As you know, I will do my
best to answer every comment
but I trust it would also be interesting
to other people watching
this video to learn
from your other experiences as well.
And, you know it, as always
if you took some value
out of this video, I'd really love you
If you hit the like button and
subscribe for more content like this.
Also big thank you to all the members
of Firm Learning for your support.
I really appreciate it.
My name is Heinrich, I
release weekly videos
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
So stay tuned until next
week until next Saturday,
all the best to you, This is Heinrich,
from Firm Learning, and bye-bye.